dis tu es payé à la vanne tu le sais 100
€ la vanne exactement
Thierry ça va pas
[Applaudissements]
on tourne pas ne fais pas le dire les
gens je t'appelle à l'oreillette tu ne
réponds pas
mais je suis en train de discuter avec
Olivier
oh non mais ce rêve dit on n'a pas fini
je te signale en vacances encore c'est
pas vous vous êtes formidable mais non
ça va pas il y a encore deux émissions à
produire mais on se fait chier là mais
là on s'emmerde c'est tout le monde
s'emmerde en régie regarde oh laisse
tomber qui c'est qui a fait ce plateau
là c'est nul c'est Tricoche oui bien
passé de pluie sur le plateau regarde
heureusement qu'il y a anguille mais
sinon
sinon c'est trop Vili non applaudit pas
les gens s'en foutent les gens s'en
foutent là-bas Olivier ça c'est bien toi
tu es bien tu fais du bateau toujours ça
c'est bien du canoë tout ça non mais
c'est intéressant mais tu peux pas
raconter une blague de cul plutôt comme
à la radio parce que la voile les gens
n'aiment pas je crois l'orange t'adore
tu sais que je t'adore c'est formidable
c'est très bien oui mettez un peu dit
qu'est-ce que tu vas qu'est-ce qui va
faire à la rentrée
ce décor dis tu es payé à la vanne tu le
sais 100 € la vanne
exactement tout à l'heure il avait une
perche là pour faire une vanne quand il
y avait le merle qui sifflet l'oiseau
pourquoi tu as pas dit Oh ben tu es
peut-être de la Noé c'est le maire de
Paris ça c'est drôle
[Applaudissements]
je te jure sinon on se ferait trop chier
pourquoi tu demandes pas des questions
de fond à Bernard pourquoi tu lui
demandes pas Condé il a payé le Togo
pour que la France a gagné
[Applaudissements]
quoi non je suis sur artistique
ça dépend des moments et puis il y a
Anggun entre les deux hein mais non on
n'est pas au chandelle qu'il est con
mais tu as du boulot je te le dis pour
la rentrée hein je te rappelle bon tu te
démerdes mais fais qu'on se bouge là
parce qu'on suit et pour être sûr de ne
rien rater
vous et mettez un pouce bleu